So I knew all the information
I don't know, Mexico.
Mala, I don't
Let me see, okay. I will break the ice cream si na is me for a hamat
The software will AR.
You see, and meat
We have a software engineer, Sheth Maha Alu
The health test entertain.
This is a letter?
Well, Badine.
Okay?
If they didn't introduce himself.
mesh, uh…
And a major track which I… cybersecurity was interested for integration.
dihi.
can, uh, deep learning datasets, the intrusion detection, including ML classification, little, uh, attacks, or cover.
which started blockchain, start the database, start with developing.
will, uh, computer science.
I was more interested in goose AIF title integration available AI will, uh, favor security.
Okay, so I'm calling. Software Layering
el epoi.
May stopgit
GitHub learning?
So
Ms. Docker.
Okay.
Mesh life
Anna Yusuf Mohammed Arabao.
Circular
For the…
Okay, the full stock.
Frontendy content.
From the Staghalt React
The act of framework in Node.js
Okay, Naurav should act then.
Lala.
software layering.
Okay.
Ouch.
Get hobbiani
You talk about, so
Doctor.
Okay. Ms. You can have that any switch receives
A fast EPIO, anakut biore nanlai agent beech documents via kazakuledabstiani m beingusada tilia tulanashan knowledge gbti hani e fast API, wise, document
Get them in… hakat basic yang meshaga gamay. Bas, bass hadik heist adi hagatani.
No, Tammy, I'm
Github, no, GitHub other will push.
See, Docker… Docker Azar
So I fully front or back end of the GCS Safari
Sama
The front end
From Sunday
Our front-end kathosito, had the intermediate CSS
Okay.
Well, okay.
We'll see another… another thing you switch
Hello.
It's me from Habehi
And, root AI engineer.
For the important day
The person
AI
AI handles the car as well
Michelle does require
CS.
Computer side
Yes, okay. Graduza?
I want to graduate
Okay
Where previous experiences
LLMs
True AI, it is any basics
People start full stack, front-end React
Django.
Mish
Okay, Flask offers the behind.
Yeah, so for Australian, very basic first API.
me shopping.
A.
The engineering… engineering policy, yes.
Cs
Okay.
Or let's somehow AI engineering, right?
Niche, okay. And also, Dr.
Sort of
And the basic knowledge of GitHub.
Okay.
In the colors?
Hello?
Come sir?
So many attractive, I want to,
Hello?
Zahrud.
I also…
Uh, that's why I won't have it.
Almighty
Okay.
of MSA University, major software engineering for computer science.
knowledge engine.
And then I said, passion.
symptoms of corona.
I mean, but did we deal with any survey questions?
In English.
Okay.
Back in the…
website application.
We're…
website.
website, front end of it.
And website, they'll front end can be very
React
We have to Node.js.
Mongo?
Maresigible.
MongoDB
MongoDB.
Okay.
Uh, Docker ester altrives.
Does the end of the time.
Okay, Macylabaothi, baido naanal cloud.
greeting.
Okay, so you can get to this home
GitHub app.
Okay, hello
Come on, I'm gonna
Okay, hat thingy
cosmei oil.
Where computer vision control disease detection
blank visit
Docker will.
Yeah, I
Okay, so I fully stack
And that, you know, the front end hydro rack
You're welcome.
Which helps.
An internship.
Okay?
Okay, if you…
Okay, fellow, angiulo, aya ag verminke. Kalam datasaki.
But I will point
Can you point meetings, Learner A2, give them, give them, give them. Meeting. Sprint planning, yomil hat, lawsi dah bin plantana Sprintaya.
I meet in Palestine, Sprint of planning. Okay, for that we need. Intu leisent abnu maba bat
soup, but it was the soup
Okay, I had the main project.
So ma'am, Father Learner A2.
Okay? And Adobe games, nana agai, na na after brainstorm tools.
Discussion, of course, okay? So, ditangi note.
Output tolerances, okay?
Well, Project Diane knowledge passive project
You see?
Okay, for that. Shahida get feje alla masalin salid.
Actually, in kolah boys.
I mean, obviously
Sorry.
Can you backlink the software engineer
You see, the structuring will lead in the calculation
Missing fevers are.
But Anna, when the experience landed also to put the heart of Enhoy engineering.
Okay?
An eye examine the same as an eyes enemy
Hey guys, amalla animation. SVG any harukaarama.
Alice, whatever. At all videos.
An Isaac family. Kaza.
Oaxas…
Voi food.
Okay? They haven't had a change, how does such a software engineer from Mondo?
Okay, del boy pudding. We had the software engineer.
At the Wildfast Lane Infrastructure Cafe, the bottom gate. Would they come in besides the modularity Cafe
Where do you scale?
However, ring.
You see, Fadi, I'm about to tay the Kalim kufi
Hagang soil hagan
Lovely.
You can see application aufihagasma
Air table.
I'd like to ask melt
Alright, if we'll, uh, will backlog…
Go ahead and assign…
Oh, bless.
So, if I'm going to check it any inventory
A layout, week one, okay, we'll head it
Okay, sir, ma'am?
And then
So it had to handle
Now, is there anything that is the truth
strong points, weak points
Okay?
What about the day afternoon
I'm not about, uh…
But, uh, heavyweight projects…
Venezuelan muscle in gali task,
Da
Some of the Asian bordung shaykh.
At the local.e.
Pantalofitas, intamacan intamacan se, hanam el Asian intimacenan bian will simplani.
Okay? Bansai insanandakshi knowledge.
I mean, obviously.
Bassefehimatal al nukhiah. Nais had the flexible.
I did when we started, even
Awesome, awesome.
In flexibility.
Uh, West Coast, a general dynamics.
I am.
Okay, Mr. Arman, this mosquill.
And at the moment, we'll let them.
Place, machine.
Elaine, if you have logged in bedroom
present to them in CEOs through shift. Ay had blok i report. Bas hi haga borda muhenna, mesh au no ratul te kalen. Autenanta blog.
Mr. Gurdu, keep in mind, in the
I mean, it had to do a
Oh, at the moment.
Well, projectir.
I thought.
Okay.
The Alan Group will host everyone there. I don't know Sarah Halifa, I really mentioned, Robi hida?
Okay, wait.
Topalos, okay.
I think, in fact, Emily mentioned, a group that's everyone, then a group there, and
Everyone meeting
Everyone hotel group
The lower dal?
Lunch at Table Circle
Now, application
Okay.
El estender meetings. Kazu.
Ms. Hali Ranit.
content generation, our video generation. Arsenal videos in the Instagram
Abas.
I feel hidden deep
Hey, hey.
Instagram.
There was the market
AI tool
Okay.
V3.
They…
V-E-O.
Uh, we, uh, IVR.
Modest video generation.
Maybe I will point along.
The Lord documents by Mukhtalaf Ashkalha, embedding values language chain beta integrles.
The language talifa
For website volume. Command language
model interaction
PDF files, PowerPoint files, CSV files, or Excel, koladabi kund, knowledge base
vector database
The phase with PromoDB and act as a knowledge base, then LLM will accept the data.
Hi, Shufto
Oh
Okay, how are expected of
kufi.
Oh, and this is
Yeah, resources, resources, of course
Resources.avissot
Yeah, I think this is achievable, but resources aligned.
Resources A and Hakata icons will…
Okay.
And struggle isn't through tools
And style agent stores.
e-learning.
With new le masakh language. Symbol inputs.
And script
I'm a Malaysian script
These are script.
Script
And input data persona, backstory of the entire customizable agent that I will prompt
With all that input of an eye exam and engineering video language training. Salali ba script
Two minutes maximum. One minute maximum
I want to make muslin with you about cas.
Okay?
The adoptional Interface.
With customizable prompt, we do with the input, we can, like, script for the hour stage, alhamdulillah.
Okay? Lawal script.
Halali Script. Badim
The slides, a number of slides in the image slightly slides.
Use the allocate
Okay, okay.
next stage.
You see, the thing, I think, but so far, I've been disabled as the moccan, temp. Vajo el es mitz sevmo que en frijagasma passing.
Family nosdi
Asians.
It does not there
lofty agent. Where famous?
The nice prompt output.
We had advantage. Mei si?
Team planning. Can EC planning. Kadam afrosi ba ei sin.
Sa.
PowerPoint.
Yeah, this is a script, same other slides.
Steam planning.
Team planning, and it had assembly descriptives.
Okay.
But this any planning. If it was scene planning script
I'm missing planning. I will describe. Tani sin hate al ecom ladi, talesin hait alagmaladi, ocha kasi. Sa?
So, if any mafrozen planning, it's la visual… visual cue, a visual cue da que envoy kendan el visual.
And to our finishing soil?
Oh
Michelle skin tiga?
Tryphine, sir
Hello
machine?
The one has structure, ni si?
Missinger
Scene one
In Wanda?
kung fi visual
2.
You see a visual QG. Masalan icon of, Masalani Hagaba, of database, Nasalan
Appears
Hello?
Are you, are you on?
Hawaiian, another charge.
Hello, Ditao
Nesh, okay
Minimal salon?
Okay, and I will hang on, I want
Script for e-learning
With you explaining
Language chain
In only one
2 minutes
Maximum
Once
Hello?
Hmm.
Okay? I want you to plan this script
Things, food
With you? Generation
Each scene
Must have
Text narration
of the script
Visual.
icons… oh, okay.
Make
Huh.
Okay? On the screen, divid sine tu
Imagine building an AI chatbot with language model can answer questions.
The description
animations in language in 3 languages open source framework
Hmm.
I'll pop up
Amien.
Hmm
Okay.
Tani hide
CTS.
Model Bab, whatever model C models in OpenAI with Gemini, whatever tactile script
Huh, I always welcome
Nathani
Ma'am, Tom
toy.
Robust step, robust
Andersonal level
We also had the results of sinking.
You see?
Can I do a change invoice? Hello, my name is Mentor A Shah Paella Kazan
Hello?
Right? Name is Mentor A, Dimasar and
While the individual kil.
Okay? But the website's myan naturadarong kibo men halaikondi, wala junihuha minivatal.
voiceover.
If voice over why it is LGB.
Let me see
And together.
MLA
Nothing.
In the script is einstan de lac masalamin zirulitni
Hello? My name is Ishi Badi Menethne Hansa. I am, my name is Mentor A Ahmad
Okay.
I am software engineer.
Okay? Masalan await si now.
Okay?
Muscle and hands
Same hoi.
MH4 parah
Estaniel Hansa?
engineering mall
I wasn't have to.
Hamili?
Yes, do I change the mic?
Okay? Zaida. Shipping.
I'm a software engineer. Yanny di mak tuba hin. Hello, my name is Mentor A, I'm software engineer. Okay? Transcription, sa timestamp
I'm standing selected. Pardon
Hawaii, transcription time standing.
Okay?
Hamila
So ma'am, hello, okay, the license
Uh, I'm at the transcript, Levittla on YouTube.
Bizzok
As a NASA.
Does the fashion or fashioni video
Missy? Bhatt festa niatal taktala imid julfura. Imtain.
My calamity.
And besides the family gamma.
planning.
Hmm
Hi, Alison
sixth.
Second, Mahoud Betul Gumla.
Hmm.
rocksette.
Malvoicing.
discussions, these discussions, leave Vu Bimba.
Okay, have a sales moment. Hello?
Okay? So,
the overview, in projects.
Manala Air Force, if they will
Okay.
Oh, an almost mineral pipeline.
pipeline blueprint, DV scheme.
with asynchronization job model.
Okay. Nama fruit.
I think any tofu, that local invitation
branch
You see?
Don't know.
Bye, ma'am.
And me, Ms. Leslie, we are some photos
Okay.
I would like to see any
Hello, and mesa kel transcript
We had domestically.
Okay…
My fruit than a libetlamil transcript.
I script that?
I mean, obviously
Hmm, the main way
Hmm.
The Batumab.
the bottom
I'll back end, the back end, diamond, poison, chuffon poison, flask API.
Machine, an agent, crew AI
Nishi?
Chrome, okay
through AI. LLMs will have moha, hatab al juminay wal OpenAIGA bid deben dal aft. Yan na na fi project.
per malice.
I'll observability pattern, output.
And he will.
May she, okay?
missed it.
Missing
Oh, okay,
Hello, Samil. Mr. Benes Babal shock. Akin bush talk forward.
May she listened.
Aj
hotel,
An Agent definition material.
assets generation. Ha.
The consumer lymphoma del consumer.
I mean, obviously
branches will features Caiku.
lobian sabas.
database schema?
Oh.
Make sure, okay.
An issue, okay. And either authentication, international database
And I thought the… database management system, Kutanako,
Hello, I had the SQL database.
Uh, 6…
Salty
Estante SQLite, estal Oracle…
tickle.
Nice side.
Is it?
Don't miss, miss.
Visually appealing table users with table videos
domain.
Dakal
Oh, come in.
SQL.
Okay?
Uh, Heraclius Island Cyclus.
Welcome to Shaizano Sikul.
Oh, Amesh, man.
Okay, relation.
So, man.
And besides, sort of a brief explanation because the description
And our family is
And he held senior presentation and baseline layout
Static slide layout.
Madima, Mamil Sin.
Okay.
Was so elevation.
This is a family animations, men whom
deep learning, hagas maham mask kuma.
Hello, Saman
The E
Masking, masking
My email list.
Masking
Hello?
Okay?
El masking families, they… the family. Tamila.
Alas.
Oh
Time
The poison.
Hmm.
And I can see why icons.
Hello?
I see iconic icons, oksteja milal hamasalan esta planning, masal nil oikum kasatisa rashmail, aki description inauma zay.
Sufinib to Zaharhamdu.
Okay, so in my ketar hacer bet akin, sachen schiz amel hagamat… first generation listen,
Yeah, scene one, scene two
And do a tiny description or narration.
multi-generation.
Oh, Yanni.
Hmm.
casa.
Tell me.
When my uncle dies, vassels die attack.
Because render our render job schema, we have nil pipeline
Palmer, what about
Yusuf Muhammad.
You said Muhammad as well
Mozboot
MB4.
animation.
With the Hagat Mabadashun La Biju, barakari voice overali, barkat talal m before. Hetalt le.
Okay.
I break down
Bizar
Oh, Stout Korea.
Okay, definitely integrates our
About local harbat, local.
Then what? Okay
Oh…
Bill specifications koal loci.
In April, sir
list specifications.
Nishoka.
You see, specifications.
Basimultas description ham hega email meeting.
to come.
Tamil
In the project year, but only the project, the advanced book dear, tell the momentum about.
Rakuten task.
That's how
Anyhow, line, I think it's see.
Vishi?
Okay.
InshaAllah
Bye bye.